[Music]
foreign
brought to you by the every dollar app
start budgeting for free today I didn't
think it was possible with the Epic
student loan debacle
for it to get any Dumber out there but
it has it's not good Dave
student loan repayment four million
people have enrolled in Biden's save
plan ahead of the payment restart
according to cnn.com yes now we know a
lot of these people were probably
automatically enrolled it says the
majority of them so basically CNN's
headline is a lie yeah four million
people enroll in Biden's save plan ahead
of payment restart no they didn't the
vast majority of them were automatically
defaulting default enrolled they didn't
voluntarily enroll they didn't actively
enroll so they didn't enroll that's
right you pushed them in like you pushed
them in that's not enrolling
and so the majority of them came out of
the other program that failed called
repay and now we're in to save because
we have to have acronyms in Washington
for our stupidity right it makes it
sound better than what it is because
what it is is a trap God this thing is
awful it says launched earlier this
summer The save plan save they call it
saving on a valuable education that's
laughable it's available available to
most people with federal student loans
and this is what they're saying it can
provide an air quote significant relief
to borrowers struggling to pay off their
student debt
I would not be struggling to pay off
it'd be struggling to pay yeah it does
it does do that yeah okay so basically
if you sign up or accidentally were
enrolled even though you didn't enroll
in the new save plan and you're one of
those four million lost souls here's
what you're signed up for uh you have a
formula based on the poverty level that
dictates the dollar amount per month
that you are to pay
if it does not cover the interest being
charged on your student loan the
interest does not accrue
however one hundred percent so in other
words if the interest on your student
loans fifty dollars a month and the
formula says you only have to pay thirty
dollars a month you don't have any extra
interest at it on they forgive the
twenty dollars but what they fail to
mention is one hundred percent of the
thirty dollars goes to interest
consequently what is happening to your
student loan balance
here's what I want not moving it's
sitting there doofus sitting there like
a frog on a log
my God how dumb are you people in
Washington let's sign up people forgive
a portion of their interest allow them
to pay a tiny little payment with the
promise of debt forgiveness uh which you
always lie about up there I mean
perpetually why about up there when are
you people gonna wake up oh my God it's
dumb this is ridiculous it's ridiculous
and here's my thing I'm like okay the
interest they say it's not going to
accumulate or that it will be forgiven
at the end of your term which by the way
the term starts if you let's say you
have 12 000 just 12 000 Dave okay in
student loans okay the Forgiveness
starts at 10 years of payments
so they want you to keep a twelve
thousand dollar debt no it's 20 years of
payments they're proposing to bring it
back to 10. the proposal's not gone
through right now let me show you here
Biden proposed counseling up to twenty
thousand dollars unlike one-time Council
yeah they're unlike one-time
cancellation proposal is to say plan can
benefit both current and future
borrowers which new people that are
getting their student loan debt can sign
up for this ridiculous moronic thing
also the Biden Administration first said
it was developing a new repayment plan
last August save is expected to cost
over no that's not the one limit this
isn't where's this this is not the
article this is different so what it is
is if you have you you get in at twelve
thousand twelve thousand dollars equals
ten years of payments and for every
additional thousand Dave that you owe so
thirteen oh you're paying for 11 years
yeah 14 000 you're paying for 12 years
Max is after 20 years they promised to
forgive whatever's left exactly so after
you've done nothing for 20 years it's
going to be forgiven but let me help you
with the people that got promised that
10 years ago right that they were going
to have their loans forgiven for doing
for working for non-profits and in
underserved areas okay you remember
those people yeah yeah
000 people have applied for that
you know how many got it
1.6
so after 20 years of doing basically
nothing hoping you're going to get
forgiveness
1.6 percent of you so bad this is this
is basically the DMV of the financial
world this is the dumbest butt thing the
most inefficient socialistic garbage
I've ever seen in my life Kick the Can
down the road put your hands over yours
and go la la la la la la la la this is
not happening dumb butt idea now have I
been unclear
I hope I hadn't been unclear so how are
you going to get out of student loan
this is what you need to do guys it's
ten thousand dollars in debt deliver
pizza so easy like and make two thousand
dollars a month delivering pizzas every
night and you're done in six months yeah
and you have the rest of your life
to not be screwing around with people
like the Biden Administration oh my God
gosh yeah it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable this is ridiculous
and CNN is so stupid and you know half
the media will pick the same this this
press release by the way this headline
came from the White House yeah it did
and they republished it because it's a
lot student loan repayment four million
people enrolled enrolled Biden save plan
had nobody enrolled you automatically to
defend to it
I mean the number of people that
physically signed up for this idiocy on
purpose is very small
but they're making it well four million
people did it you should too yeah no you
shouldn't
good Lord people when are you gonna get
a clue that the White House and the
people in Washington DC are not here to
bless you these people are what you know
what this does it keeps you in debt your
whole freaking life
you're 35 years old you're 55 with
grandkids and you're still screwing
around with your college
you ought to have unbelievably naive at
best stupid at worst to believe the lies
they peddle out of the Republicans or
the Democrats regarding student loans
because let me just tell you student
loans are awful they're horrible then
why do you morons keep making them now
there's the question Dave there's a
there's a dadgum
us intellectually dishonest bunch of
people yeah you know we're going to do
everything we can to forgive your
student loans and make it easy because
there's such a burden on you while we
continue to make them to the Next
Generation you can't solve a problem
you're a freshman in high in college
right now they're going to put you 100
Grand in debt let you get a degree in
left-handed puppetry and then put you on
thirty dollars a month for the next 25
years and then lie to you about whether
we're going to forgive it at the end of
that please people don't be so stupid
this is ridiculous it's completely out
of control this I mean I read this I got
I
you know I don't know why I got pissed
off because I should expect this kind of
stupidity out of Washington yeah and I
should expect this kind of stupidity out
of the press where they put a headline
that is completely false across the stop
top I mean this is oh jeez